today on the matt walsh show the
republican governor of south dakota has
accused me of horrible misogyny quote
unquote because i criticized her she
used leftist buzzwords and even a medium
matters clip to hit me in hopes of
impressing the left but as always when
republicans try this kind of move it has
not worked out as she intended so
there's a lot we can learn from this
we'll talk about it today also dylan
roof's death penalty sentence was upheld
yesterday and yet we have not heard any
of the anti-death penalty advocates on
the left protest that decision funny
enough and a freshman orientation
seminar at a university claims that
straight white christians are natural
oppressors plus nancy pelosi calls for
congress to pass a law that will stop
hurricanes and floods from happening i'm
not sure what kind of law will do that
and our daily cancellation will discuss
the door dash delivery drivers who are
calling for higher wages and better tips
but do they really deserve it we'll
discuss that and much more today on the
matt wall show
republican legislators in south dakota
have crafted a bill called the kova 19
vaccine freedom of conscience act to
stop employers from forcing their
workers to get the cova vaccine but
christie gnome the republican governor
of the state is refusing to sign it she
argues that uh employees who don't want
to be vaccinated can just go work
somewhere else if you don't want to
inject this substance into your body go
get a new job she says also as she
stated on wednesday if she dictates
vaccine policy to businesses quote
unquote then joe biden can do the same
now this is a bizarre argument as it
suggests that the president of the
united states is looking to the governor
of south dakota for guidance or as a
precedent
but the president united states like a
true democrat doesn't even look to the
constitution or the supreme court much
less to christy gnome of south dakota he
simply does what he wants and he enacts
the policies that he prefers without any
concern for what anyone did before him
where was the precedent for the
executive branch telling all landlords
across the country that they can't evict
delinquent tenants
biden admitted that there was no
precedent that it wasn't even legal to
do it and yet he did it but this is the
difference between democrats and
feckless republicans democrats use the
power that they've been granted
and then they seize additional power
that they were not granted on top of it
republicans oftentimes most times i
would say
will not even use the legitimate
authority of the offices they hold for
fear that if they act democrats will
also act
they'd rather let the democrats act on
their own with no response or opposition
it's better to you know not get into a
fight with your opponent better to lay
down and let them stomp you into the
dust
because if you fight back it might hurt
even more
that seems to be the republican approach
even more than with the vaccine issue
gnome exemplified this way of thinking a
few months ago when she refused to sign
another republican bill which we talked
about at the time this one would have
banned biological males from competing
in female sports noam said she didn't
want to extend the ban all the way into
the collegiate level because if they do
that
then the ncaa might in her words quote
punish us
she didn't want to take a stand for
science and common sense and truth and
decency and reason for fear that such a
stand would provoke the ire of people
whose ire is constantly provoked anyway
also i suspect that it's not a
coincidence that the gnome's view on the
issue lined up perfectly with the south
dakota chamber of commerce which opposed
the bill gnome typically finds herself
in alignment with the chamber of
commerce
like a typical republican and i don't
mean that as a compliment
i also was admittedly not complimenting
christinome yesterday on this show which
you may have heard
when i theorized openly that uh her
population popularity on the right was
due to her looks
she's an attractive woman especially by
political standards
and this
i said yesterday
and still say today
explains in my opinion why she garners
all of the hype that she does
now i didn't say that her looks are the
sole reason why she's the governor of
south dakota i didn't say it's why she
has achieved any political success at
all
i said that her emergence as a
conservative icon on the national stage
is due in large part to her appearance
it's true that you know gnome never
locked down her state
and a lot of people were very a lot of
people on the right were happy about
that she garnered applause on the right
for that well-deserved applause i i
still applaud her for it
but other republican governors also
refuse to instate statewide lockdowns or
statewide mass mandates and yet many of
them have not gotten the kind of
attention that she attracts
take the republican governor of nebraska
pete ricketts let's take a look at what
what he looks like now
there's peter i guess i don't mean to
insult him he's a fine looking person in
his own way i'm sure but i
i think he will have to work a little
bit harder
to get the kind of attention that
christinome gets
okay
and the reason is obvious
it's obvious and yet it's one of the
many obvious things we're not supposed
to say out loud
we all know that there are certain
benefits and privileges that come with
being a physically attractive person we
hear a lot about privilege
okay um hot privilege that's a real
that's real privilege and there are many
scientific studies that prove this uh
generally and also specifically when it
comes to politicians
there are many of these privileges that
come with especially being an attractive
woman even more so
now we all know that
every one of us without exception we all
know that
and yet if you vocally acknowledge this
thing that we all know and agree with
every single one of us
you'll be condemned as a misogynist
now that was my experience yesterday
after discussing the subject on my show
criticizing gnome for her policies and
her lack of political courage
and then suggesting that her popularity
is due more to her physical features
media matters as is their custom clipped
that part of the program and posted it
to their website and to twitter
trying to gin up some outrage
and the attempt fell rather flat at
first frankly i was myself disappointed
by their selection because i said many
more objectionable things on the show
yesterday and i would have preferred
that they'd chosen one of those segments
instead i mean i knew they were going to
choose something because they always do
and they went with that and my first
reaction was what this is what you guys
are going with
of all of the things i said
this
that people are gravitating towards a
particular politician because of how she
looks that's the supposedly offensive
thing
nobody reacted much or cared about it
until
christinom herself the governor of south
dakota
took that media matters clip cut it down
even shorter to remove the context and
the reason for my criticism
focusing only on the part where i
comment on her looks and posted it to
her own twitter page or if actually in
fact her official governor twitter page
along with this caption it read quote
instead of engaging in a debate about
the proper role of government and how it
isn't conservative to tell people how to
do business
matt walsh stooped to horrible misogyny
eyes up here matt
but she wasn't done she then went to her
personal page
and posted again this time also telling
on me to my boss by tagging ben shapiro
and she said quote hey ben shapiro tell
matt walsh i was roping bulls maybe he's
a steer bigger than him when i was in my
teens he couldn't walk a day in my shoes
girl power
and she's right i probably wouldn't fit
in her shoes but if she was a college
athlete i could take her place on the
team according to her policies
by the way let's note that a steer okay
is a castrated bull
so that's the dig she was trying to make
there which is fine okay pretty good
insult i'm not offended by it
um
i dish it i can take it
but you can't go for the ruthless insult
while also tattling on me to my boss
hey guess what matt said ben
and also crying about horrible misogyny
you really got to pick a lane christy
you're either the toughest nails woman
riding in on your horse roping bulls
or you're a fragile feminist accusing
your critics of misogyny it's got to be
one or the other
or might i suggest you could choose
neither of those characters because they
both ring false
the rough and tumble girl power shtick
is especially inauthentic
seeing as how you know you'll go
head-to-head with a right-wing podcast
host while kowtowing to corporate
interests and the lgbt lobby
i mean where was where where were these
where was this backbone
the all the courage here where was this
when the when the ncaa was coming after
her no they'll punish us not the ncaa i
don't want to be punished
and what about this misogyny charge
is it is it sexist is it anti-woman for
me to accuse christinome of benefiting
politically from her physical
attractiveness no it isn't because for
one thing again it's true and everybody
knows that it's true
you can argue about the extent to which
it has helped but if you tell me that it
hasn't helped at all
that i'm way off in left field here
then i will know that you're either
stupid or lying
but let's pretend for a moment
that the accusation is not true
okay let's say that i am off in left
field
well then that would make me wrong
it would make me unfair perhaps even a
jerk
it would make me many things potentially
and i may be all of those things
it still wouldn't make me sexist though
because i heap extremely harsh criticism
on politicians all the time it's one of
my favorite pastimes and i believe it
should be a favorite pastime of all
red-blooded americans
i criticize male and female politicians
alike
i mean go back to some of the shows
where i was talking about asa hutchinson
governor asa hutchinson when he uh
refused to sign the bill banning the
castration of children
go check out some of the things i said
about him
quite a bit harsher in fact
now is all of my criticism of
politicians accurate
and most of it is yeah well actually all
of it is i think but but even if it
isn't the criticism is motivated by my
dislike for politicians
especially the ones that i consider to
be weak ineffectual and dishonest
it's not motivated by dislike for women
now it's probably pointless for me to
explain all this because the explanation
presupposes that the accusation was
sincere and honest in the first place
which it wasn't
no one was using a leftist buzzword and
trying to gin up left-wing outrage
against me in order to make herself the
victim and that brings us to the most
important point
and the reason that i'm talking about
all of this
here we see the critical mistake that
conservatives so often make especially
elected republicans who call themselves
conservative
gnome was using a media matters clip
and leftist language
to hit someone to the right of her
hoping to win favorability points among
people to the left of her
there'd be no other reason to do that
you're not going to be using media
matters and using the word misogynist
and attacking someone to your right
if you're trying to appeal to people to
your right now this was a play for
people to her left
did it work
uh no not remotely check social media
today to see what folks on the left are
saying about the christie gnome versus
matt walsh feud and you'll find that
they are in wide agreement
that we're both terrible people and scum
of the earth and disgraceful ignoramuses
and so on
the sympathy that gnome has gotten has
come in the form of comments like this
from a guy named brian rosenwald this is
pretty
pretty representative of the kind of
things people are saying says i think
christy gnome is terrible and her
decisions have cost people their lives
but matt walsh's comments were the
purest form of misogyny you'll ever see
he wouldn't say the same things about
ron desantis with a similar profile
it's a firing offense
but it's conservative media
well she got her wish in one respect um
people are calling for me to be fired
and yet and that obviously is what she
wanted that's again why she tagged my
boss in a tweet
and yet the people calling for me to be
fired still say that gnome herself is a
mass murdering monster
and she is
in the same way that i'm a misogynist at
least
we have seen republicans make this
mistake a thousand times thousands and
thousands of times
they criticize their own side
using leftist frameworks
in hopes of impressing the left
and then the whole thing just collapses
on them
and they're the only one who gets
crushed in the end
and that's the lesson that hopefully
we all can learn
from this
now let's get to our five headlines
you know what i hate more than anything
in this world and it's a very very long
list as you know uh going to the auto
parts store i just hate the auto parts
store and that's why i love rockauto.com
i have a i have a perhaps even
unreasonable distaste for auto parts
stores and why is it well because you
got to go there you walk around you're
looking for what you they don't have
what you need they're asking a bunch of
questions uh you can't answer the
questions and it's just it's a whole big
ordeal why not just go to rockauto.com
they always offer the lowest prices
possible so if you know that you're if
you're getting it on rockauto.com you
know that it's the best price you're
going to get anywhere else no need to
keep shopping around they're a family
business they've been serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years you can go
to rockauto.com to shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers the catalog is unique and
very easy to navigate you can quickly
see all the parts available for your
vehicle and you can choose the brands
the specifications the prices you prefer
all of it is right there rockauto.com so
go to rockauto.com right now and see all
of those parts available for your car
truck and as always remember
to give me credit for this and write
walsh in there how did you hear about
spock so they know that we sent you
all right so and i have gotten a lot of
requests from the media messages and
people messaging email me emailing
asking me first of all i'm getting a lot
of requested do you want to apologize
do you want to apologize for what you
said about christinome
newsweek a newsweek reporter is doing an
article about this and he contacted me
and said to ask if i
regret using misogynistic language about
christinome
that was the framing of the question it
wasn't do you think that your comments
were misogynistic do you regret using
misogynistic language and then he wanted
to know if i want to clarify my comments
for him he's going to give me a chance
to clarify before he writes his hit
piece calling me a misogynistic bigot
so here was my response to him uh i
emailed back and uh his guy's name was
anders and i said anders feel free to
attribute this to me on the record in
response to your quest for comment
and then my comment is no i do not
regret stating an obvious truth i will
however accept apologies from all of the
performative idiots pretending to be
offended by it
and uh he responded and said that he
will include that statement in his
newsweek article which is great so
that is my that's my general for anyone
in the media that's my general you could
you could all take that statement
uh as far as apologizing
uh i can't even say the word apology
without laughing
okay i and i and i really say this
sincerely
i would rather be dead
than issue any kind of public apology
about anything
especially to some sniveling snake in
the media
i would prefer death over sending an
email to someone in the media so i
sincerely regret and apologize for those
comments and please don't be mad at me
anymore
death seems far more appealing to that
because because that's a that's a form
of death
that's the death of your dignity as a
man and you're never going to get it
back
not ever going to happen i can tell you
that right now
even if i'm wrong i will never apologize
publicly you will never hear me say it
even if i'm wrong and i'm not wrong in
this case
but even if i was
even if i did regret my horrible
misogyny
the last thing i would ever do
is publish a statement or sit here
saying i'm so i've thought more about it
i deeply regret i'm so sorry
i think my stance on that should be
clear by now
the genre of the public apology needs to
go away
shouldn't exist
you're sorry about something if you're
really actually sorry
because you caused harm or you damaged
somebody
those are the things you should be sorry
for if you actually did something unfair
or
mean or whatever and you you hurt
somebody in some way
then you go and you find them and you
apologize to them personally
it doesn't have to be for public
spectacle
you don't know the public an apology for
anything
and especially not in this case because
i am just
unbelievably absolutely 100 right in
everything
that i said
uh if i apologize for anything it's just
for being so right about it and making
other people feel intellectually
inferior because of my rightness if i
apologize for anything it's it may be
that
all right go now to uh we'll start with
the ap which has this
report it says a federal appeals court
wednesday upheld dylan roof's conviction
and death sentence for the 2015 racist
slangs of nine members of a black south
carolina congregation
saying the legal record cannot even
capture the full horror of what he did a
unanimous three-judge panel of the
fourth u.s circuit court of appeals in
richmond rejected arguments that the
young white man should have been ruled
incompetent to stand trial in the
shootings
at mother emanuel ame church in
charleston
and uh so now
he's
still going to face the death penalty
and his mental impairment claim is not
panned out
which is great he he deserves the death
penalty obviously
um the only unfortunate thing here like
with with every death penalty case the
unfortunate thing is that this drags out
for years and years and years and years
and we've got to go through this whole
ridiculous
uh charade of keeping him alive and and
feeding him and clothing him just so
that we can eventually kill him it's
completely ridiculous
uh you might as well
back in the old days you're convicted
you're sentenced to death and then
that day or at dawn the next morning
you're marching up the gallows to be
hung by your neck until death while a
crowd watches
and that's how we should do it now
that's that that should be the uh
the way that we go about this and in
fact it's even worse it's it's even
worse than that because we're not only
housing and feeding these people on
death row for years and years and years
before eventually killing them
but on top of that we're actually
spending more money on them
because these are people who have
committed crimes especially someone like
dylan roof
committed crimes so heinous that
to release them into the general
population would be just a death
sentence in and of itself
i wouldn't complain about that either by
the way
but we're not going to do that and so
we've got to specially protect them and
preserve their lives just think about
how absurd it is
we have to make this extra effort
to preserve their lives and protect them
just so that we can march them to the
gurney and kill them
it really doesn't make any sense it's
ridiculous now so that's how i feel
about this as someone who
um
although i felt differently about the
about the death penalty years ago and i
have kind of gone back and forth on this
as i admit but
at this point i'm pretty firmly
pro-death penalty so that's that's where
i stand on on dylan roof that's a that's
an easy one
but the interesting thing is that
you know there are a lot of people in
this country especially on the left
who are
very much opposed to the death penalty
at least they claim that
they think the death penalty should be
abolished that it's state-sanctioned
murder
you know they're they're opposed to it
in in every case and there's been there
have been many monstrous people who have
faced the death penalty
and
have been defended by many people unless
including very prominent people
members of the squad and so forth
have come out
in defense of absolute murderous
monsters
and yet in this case
i have heard
none of those voices as far as i know
i haven't heard any of those people on
the left
especially the prominent ones come out
and say no no this is wrong dylan roof
doesn't deserve the death penalty
so they make an exception for him which
is interesting
why do they make the exception well
because for one thing
they just they don't
believe in their own principles in any
of their own principles enough
to actually stand up and say no this man
who who murdered nine uh black people at
a church
you know should shouldn't shouldn't be
uh killed
um
so they don't they don't believe in
their own in their own principles enough
for that
but also i think
they look at a crime like this
and they just they they feel that no
this is someone who who can't exist on
earth anymore
you've committed a crime so heinous that
you
you don't deserve to be defended you
don't deserve to live anymore you have
forfeited your right to live on this
earth you have forfeited your right
to be
a member of human society
what you've done is so heinous that we
can't even
simply segregate you and keep you in
human society we have to remove you
completely by your own actions you have
made that choice for yourself you've
forced our hand
i think they look at dylan roof and
that's that's what they think and
they're right
the problem is they can't extend that
to all of the other monsters on death
row
and they are all monsters you don't get
there unless you are
so they could see that with dylann roof
they can't see it with anybody else
a real disconnect there
this is from fox that says james madison
university is under fire for pushing
controversial rhetoric as part of its
freshman orientation training for
student leaders
the powerpoint presentation and
accompanying video addressed topics like
social justice identity power and
privilege
and labeled any person who fits the
parameters of white male straight and
christian as oppressors in a detailed
chart
jmu college republicans chairwoman
juliana mcgrath
shared her frustration with fox news
saying the training at the virginia
university that's meant to bring
students together will ultimately be
divisive
she said quote when you're teaching
about things like this the goal is to
try to bring people together and try to
get people to understand different life
experiences but by saying because you're
white you're an oppressor because you're
straight you're an oppressor because
you're a male you're an oppressor that
actually brings people farther apart and
it doesn't actually accomplish any of
the goals of what i feel like they were
trying to do
according to mcgrath the most shocking
inclusion in the presentation was the
implication that followers of the
christian faith specifically were deemed
as oppressors even though all religious
individuals regardless of denomination
believe in the same thing a higher power
she said quote in our chapter of college
republicans we actually have a very
diverse chapter and we have
people of different races of different
backgrounds and specifically of
different religious beliefs and that's
always been very welcome i feel like no
matter your political beliefs you always
find some type of common ground i think
sometimes religion is the common ground
so on and so forth okay
uh
a lot of this unfortunately is
unremarkable because we've these this is
the kind of re-education
that we see in colleges across the
country
uh most
universities at this point this is their
primary function
this is a
feature not a bug
it's not like you send your kids to
college and then they just so happen to
be brainwashed into leftist dogma that's
why the universities exist at this point
that is their primary goal
so that makes this unremarkable but
but still important
but i'm really
i really zero in on what she said here
um
juliana mcgrath
she said the goal is to try to bring
people together and try to get people to
understand different life experiences
but when you do all of this you're
you're tearing people apart
and that doesn't accomplish any of the
goals that you're that you're trying to
accomplish she said
well no juliana let me explain this to
you it is important that you understand
i don't be accused of mansplaining here
okay i don't need that on top of all the
other crimes i've committed
maybe that'll be next maybe christy
gnome
tomorrow will tweet about how i
mansplained
she'll at this point just dye your hair
pink
cut it down
call me a man explainer why not
go full feminist anyway
it is important to explain this uh to
anyone who doesn't understand it i think
there are a lot of people on the right
who still don't understand this
um
no the these these kind of
indoctrination seminars
where they're saying that white people
and males and christians are oppressors
and evil and all that
this is not a misguided but
well-intentioned attempt
to bring people together and to make
people understand each other's life
experiences no
this is not something that's clumsy and
we'll say well they're they're trying to
accomplish something they're just not
accomplishing it
they just so happen to be doing the
opposite of what they're trying trying
to accomplish no they are accomplishing
their goal 100
the goal is not to bring anyone together
that is not the goal
the division the hostility the suspicion
that's engendered by these sorts of
programs that is the point that's why
they're doing it
there is nothing well intentioned about
this at all
they are trying to drive that wedge in
between you in between all of us
and not one wedge but a million wedges
dividing people into a million different
categories and subcategories
even one single individual person is now
divided in is is chopped into into a
thousand different pieces and put into
different compartments and different
labels and everything everybody's
warring against each other
that is
totally the point it's why they're doing
it
so when you say they're not achieving
what they want to achieve yes they are
they are doing a great job of
accomplishing their goals
they want to divide the american
population
uh they
to to inflame
tribalism that's part of the point here
and also
to to tear down
our history and all of the authorities
of the past
you know to separate us from our own
history
we western civilization
is informed
shaped by christian values by the
christian religion
and that's why that's one of the main
reasons why they hate it
and that's why if you notice they focus
on christianity
much more than they focus on something
like islam
because they are trying to destroy
eat away at chop down the foundations of
western civilization
that that is the point
they want us to live fully immersed
in modernity
severed from all of the ties of the past
hating everybody that came before us
our ancestors all of the people who
built this civilization that we now live
in
they want us to hate all of them and
hate all that hate our past
hate anybody connected with our past
they want to identify the villains of
the past
in a very simplistic way well if you're
a white if you're a christian if you're
a male
those are all the villains of the past
any any of the your historical heroes
who you thought were heroes well if
they're they were white male whatever
and they weren't heroes they were they
were oppressors
and their progeny to this day still
oppressors
that is
again the whole entire point
and it is crucially important for us to
understand that all right next nancy
pelosi yesterday talked about uh what we
can do to prevent floods and storms and
uh here she is on that
we uh when we talk about challenges that
we have in our country we have these
fires in the west floods in tennessee
president uh
approved a major disaster declaration
for tennessee middle tennessee region
has had flooding and deaths in
california we had the river in the west
we had the river and dixie
fires which the president has declared
major disasters for as well and so we
have to understand how
again many of us think if we take if we
can address the climate crisis we can
deal
in a better way to prevent
uh some of this
uh yeah so we want to pass legislation
that's going to stop floods from
happening
and stop hurricanes and fires
that's what they're that's what they're
calling for this is this is
we should be heaping ridicule and scorn
and contempt on this sort of thing
i i'm afraid that we don't treat it as
in in you know as absurd as it really is
we don't treat it like the absurdity
that it actually is
and part of it is that
like so many other absurdities in modern
culture we're used to it by now
we're used to hearing politicians
seeing them stand in front of cameras
talking about laws they can pass to
change the weather
and we hear it so often that we it kind
of goes right over our head
but think about how insane that is
you think that
that some politicians
can you know type out some legislation
and then vote on it and it's going to
change the
the weather
you think you're that powerful not only
is this anti-scientific which it is
but it speaks to the incredible
narcissism
of these people
and i and i believe that they really
believe it they believe that they are
gods they are more powerful
than the sun itself which as we talked
about yesterday is actually the thing
this enormous ball of gas which you
could fit a million earths inside of it
burning 27 million degrees fahrenheit at
its core 10 000 degrees on the surface
gravitational force
extending 12 trillion miles into space
like that is the thing that determines
the weather on this puny tiny little
planet
is there's nothing you can do nancy
pelosi i'll tell you this right out not
a single thing you can do
to make any significant changes to it
and the earth's uh temperatures and its
climate
it changes climate is meant to change
so even the phrase climate change is
redundant that's what climates do of
course they change
and the earth by the earth endures
the earth has endured super volcano
eruptions the earth has endured uh
asteroids
the size of entire states hitting the
the the earth
or the size of cities anyway i should
say
um
the earth endures all of that
because we're that we are not that
powerful you're the suv that you drive
or the hvac system that you turn on
it's not quite as powerful as you want
it to be and the legislation that you
write is also not as powerful as you
want it to be
i hate to inform you
all right this is an interesting case
from bbc.com it says spencer eldon the
man who was photographed as a baby on
the album cover for nirvana's never mind
is suing the band alleging sexual
exploitation
the cover depicts elden as a
four-month-old
in a swimming pool i mean you've seen
this cover it's an iconic cover uh you
got a four-month-old baby naked in a
swimming pool and he's grasping for a
dollar bill that's dangled in front of
him the dollar bill was superimposed
into the
picture after it was taken
um
but now eldon says that his parents
never signed a release authorizing the
use of his image on the album
and he also alleges the nude image
constitutes child pornography
he said quote
or legal papers filed in california say
the images exposed spencer's intimate
body part
and uh displayed spencer's genitals from
the time he was an infant to the present
day
eldon's lawyer robert lewis argues that
the inclusion of the dollar bill makes
the minor seem like a sex worker
i hadn't seen that until i just read
this the legal case also alleges that
nirvana had promised to cover elton's
genitals with a sticker but the
agreement was not upheld well this is
clearly
clearly absurd this also means that
every baby that's been in like a diaper
advertisement
they could all sue for
for based on child pornography first of
all if you're going to sue anyone then
it would be your parents
they're the ones who
brought you for this album cover shoot
and apparently threw you into a pool so
i think they're the ones who i would be
uh who i would take this up with but
if you really want to know how absurd
this is this guy spencer eldon
he has through the years on like three
or four different occasions
has recreated that album cover
uh to mark the anniversaries of the
album so like the 10th anniversary 15th
20th i think
i think all three of those
he went and he recreated he was very
happy about it he's recreating this
album cover that he now says was child
pornography and exploitation
but i this this is the world we live in
you might as you you see a chance in our
litigious society you see a chance to
file a lawsuit make some money why not
do it that's what's going on here and
finally from the daily wire it says
though comedy central has been airing
reruns of nbc's beloved long-running
sitcom the office for years
there's one episode you may not be able
to find on the network going forward and
that is diversity day the episode is
famous for its politically incorrect
storyline which features boss michael
scott forcing the paper company staff to
participate in a racially in a racial
diversity seminar where he speaks in an
exaggerated indian accent and reprises
chris rock's notorious stand-up routine
about different kinds of black people
according to bar stool sports the
channel the cable channels quietly
omitted the episode from the rotation
uh comedy central has not
admitted that they're doing this but
if you watch the whole rotation of
office
reruns on comedy central you're not
going to find that one
and this of course is no shock this is
this is only a matter of time
people who are fans of the office like
myself at least i'm a fan of the office
from
the first season until the middle of the
fourth season
and i don't acknowledge any other
episodes of the office after that
because it fell off of a cliff
especially after steve carell left in
season six
uh
but fans of the office we have have
known for a long time that this is
coming
all all good comedy eventually will be
canceled
because it's all offensive
because almost all comedy almost all
good comedy anyway
is based on you know poking fun at human
beings and human nature
comedy is supposed to
kind of
point us to things that we're not
supposed to talk about
comedy is supposed to kind of desecrate
the sacred cows in in culture that is
one of the functions of comedy and
comedians that's the service they
provide to their societies and it's an
important service
but we can't have that anymore so this
is only a matter of time
and of course the irony is that
we all knew that these episodes were
going to go away especially diversity
day i mean for years office fans have
been saying this they're that that
they're going to start getting rid of
these episodes and that's going to be
the first one to go
because it's all based around uh racial
stereotypes and so on
but the irony is that we're supposed to
be we're not laughing really at the
racial stereotype you're supposed to be
laughing at michael scott who is this
oaf who doesn't understand social
conventions and doesn't understand he's
not even intentionally being politically
incorrect he just is because he's stupid
that's the joke anyway
so you're not even laughing at the
racial stereotype you're laughing at the
person who is engaging these racial
stereotypes
and even that you're not allowed to do
because it acknowledges the stereotype
to begin with
and yeah part of what makes it funny and
kind of cringy is that there's there's
some truth to most stereotypes
so you can't do that
that's going to go away and this is this
is progress though when we start
erasing these episodes
can't laugh about it can't joke about it
it's supposed to be progress
in reality it's the exact opposite
because you know that you've achieved
there's never going to be and was never
going to be in any culture including our
own
absolute perfect utopian
racial harmony that's there's never
gonna be any kind of perfect utopian
harmony in this life anyway that's what
the next life
is for but
you know you've gotten as close to that
as you can possibly get
when you've got different groups of
people who can joke about themselves and
each other and they can laugh about it
that's how you know a group of friends
are really close friends when they can
poke fun at themselves but also poke fun
at each other make fun of each other
even be kind of ruthless
in their uh insults and laugh about it
that's how you know you're comfortable
with somebody else
and we could do that when it came to
racial jokes even as recently as uh
you know 12 13 years ago
and now you can't and that's that's a
sign that we're going in
the wrong direction
all right next we move to our comments
cool papa j magic says i love how gen z
are actually the ones saying pornography
is ruining our lives while middle-aged
men are saying it's our right to watch
it seems backwards but it makes total
sense yeah i've noticed that as well i
don't know if we looked at the surveys i
i'm sure they would find that the
majority of people in gen z
have very permissive attitudes about
pornography but it is also interesting
to note
that right now these sort of anti-porn
movement is fueled largely by young
people even people
younger than myself i don't even know if
i qualify as a young person anyway but
it is that is a it's a young movement
that is speaking out against this and
even if they're not in the majority
which i'd say they almost certainly
aren't though i wish they were
that's a powerful statement
and one of the things that makes it
powerful is that especially with gen z
these are our people
kids who grew up with this
i mean a lot of these kids a lot of
these these young men now
who are speaking out against porn
culture
they were probably exposed to it for the
first time when they were like
seven and
so when they talk about the dangers of
pornography they're not talking in a
theoretical academic sense
they're saying if you listen to them
they're saying this is what it's done to
me this is the effect it's had on me and
my friends i've lived in this culture
and this environment i know what it's
like
that it's dreary and depressing and
perverse and corrupting
and empty and hollow
they're speaking very much from
experience
all of the older peop middle-aged people
the boomers who are still valuably
defending the rights of pornographers
and pimps and smut peddlers
they didn't grow up in in that kind of
environment they created that kind of
environment for their kids to grow up in
but they didn't grow up in it
they got to have their innocence
at least for a time
their kids never got it
and if they were to listen to their kids
their kids are mourning the fact that
they never had that innocence
all right liam says to further matt's
idea of adult content actually being sex
starved it's something akin to how you
can starve a cat by feeding them tuna
please don't they'll eat the tuna
because of the taste and they think it's
satisfying but it also has almost zero
nutritional value for them the same is
true for people that only consume those
types of videos
they're not really getting anything they
need and what's more they'll continue to
not seek out something fulfilling well
right that's exactly right that's that's
that's why it uh
breeds addiction
like any other drug
yeah you could use the example of well
tuna for a cat or you can use the
example of junk food
someone who sits around drinking soda
all day it tastes good in the moment but
you're not actually hydrating yourself
you're destroying your body in the
process
but i think drugs
provide the best
example because there's certainly
nothing fulfilling there you get the
high in the moment
the high diminishes
and you have to keep chasing it and
chasing and chasing it
and that's where a lot of times you go
to the harder drugs and everything else
uh
and it's the same thing with with
pornography and there is as you note
there is no fulfillment
that's the one thing that is missing
in an in an actual human romantic
relationship with a flesh and blood
person
it's not gonna be perfect you're gonna
have your arguments and your strife but
there's real fulfillment there you feel
fulfilled with this person you feel
content
if it's a good relationship and you
found the right person
there's no contentment with pornography
uh
nick says i will genuinely always regret
not throwing my hat in the ring for the
sweet baby gang anthem but whatever
anthem is selected i will stand by it
till the end well thank you sir and uh
and i and i
mourn
your own regrets
and i know there are many such cases
because
the deadline is over
no more submissions
and now it's just a matter of uh
discovering who is going to be our true
what what will our true sweet baby gang
anthem be we're going to find that out
very soon
um
let's see
rich says i like matt but his argument
on prostitution sex work sucks
phrasing rich phrasing
using his logic he's not really
different than a sex worker
uh
okay
that's what you're gonna have to explain
a little bit how how am i similar to uh
maybe i don't want to know in what way
you find me similar to a sex worker
now if you mean i i think i already
addressed this that
yeah everybody in a s
you can try to claim that everybody who
has a job and makes a living is selling
their body because they're using their
body to do whatever they do unless
they're unless they're using the powers
of esp or mental telepathy or something
and just sitting there and moving
objects around with their mind um unless
they have that ability the rest of us
are going to be using our body in some
way to perform a task
and that goes for podcast hosts and and
construction workers and everybody right
but as i explained the difference is in
all these other jobs
uh you're using yourself
to perform some sort of task some kind
of skill
and it's that skill that you're or the
thing that you're producing which you're
selling in this case i'm making a
podcast
and that's the product that i'm selling
as it were right
uh if you build tables that you're using
your body to build a table and you're
you're selling that
but in the case of a so-called sex
worker
especially somebody as we talked about
we were specifically speaking about
people on only fans although it goes for
all of them but especially the
prostitutes on only fans
you know they're they're just displaying
their body on camera there's no art
there's nothing to it there's no skill
and they're selling their body that's
that is the object of the product that
is on the shelf
to be bought it is objectification by
its definition it is dehumanizing by its
definition
it has to be dehumanizing
you know the porn
consumer
it is the whole thing doesn't work if
the porn consumer really thinks of the
person behind the screen on the other
side of the screen as a person as a
human being
as the porn consumer if you really
reflect on the humanity of this person
and the fact that this might be a mother
this is a daughter this is someone who
you know this was a at one point a young
child this was a
an innocent young child at one point
whose life went horribly wrong i mean if
you start reflecting on all of those
things
then um
that's going to take you out of the mood
that you want to be in as the porn
consumer
so it depends on the person dehumanizing
themselves and you going along with that
you've both kind of agreed to put their
humanity and your own really on hold
and that really is the difference
it's that time again folks your favorite
time of the day and that is the daily
wire promos and i got three of them for
you today so
what's it like to be part of the fastest
growing conservative media company in
the country join us and find out daily
wire has several open positions at our
headquarters in nashville tennessee so
go check them out at dailywire.com
careers currently we're looking for a
podcast marketing manager to join our
marketing team if you're someone with a
lot of experience and passion for
growing podcasts a creative and
strategic thinker and a self-starter
then go apply
right now and you'll have your work cut
out for you selling this show right here
we're also hiring a web marketing
specialist to do well a bunch of
technical stuff on dailywire.com i don't
really know exactly what they're
supposed to do but they do something
anyway both positions are based in
nashville for in-office work if you
think you're qualified for either role
go apply now
to dailywire.com careers our team is
constantly growing so keep checking the
careers page for new opportunities and
also as lockdowns curfews mass mandates
and vaccine passports begin to pop up
around the world it's important that we
as americans question and discuss the
actions currently being taken by the
reigning administration that's why we're
going to be doing a backstage tonight to
discuss and debate the issues with
myself ben shapiro jeremy boy michael
knowles andrew clayton we're all going
to be there seven o'clock p.m eastern
time sixth period central on
dailywire.com or on our youtube channel
on uh which is the daily wire right now
also it's no secret that the truth is
hard to come by if you're listening to
the legacy media that's why we started
our newest podcast morning wire which
has been topping the apple on spotify
charts since its recent release it's the
only daily news podcast that values your
time
and the truth and while we're working
working overtime to bring you the news
you need to know we need your help to
keep the facts trending towards number
one so subscribe and start listening now
to morning wire on apple spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts and
leave a five star review if you like
what you hear wow those reads were a
mess now we're gonna get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
today for our cancellation we have a fun
twist on an old story a door dash
delivery driver who goes by the handle
french fry thug online recently recorded
a video where he claimed that he had
gotten a little bit of revenge on a
customer who didn't tip him uh here it
is
this video is for amy amy i just
delivered your food hi
i left you a note with your food and
says dear amy if you can't afford to tip
then you should go pick it up yourself
who do you think you are to order food
and have someone come and bring it to
your door for free for free i just drove
my personal car to your house to deliver
your food for fun nah
not today you can write your wrongs
below
venmo i forgot to tip you me no hard
feelings you just can't have people
bring you your food for free okay this
is a learning lesson for everyone all
right
so we're used to hearing stories where a
waiter or delivery driver claims that a
customer left them a nasty note but in
this case the delivery driver claims
that he left the nasty note
now as we saw even just last week the
nasty notes stories
are almost always hoaxes and i say
almost only to leave open the slight
possibility that there's been a real
incident at some point this century
though if there was a real one i don't
think we ever heard about it what about
this one though well here again again
he's saying that he left the note
can't we trust that i mean would he lie
about leaving his own note would someone
really be so starved for a star for
attention and also so much of a
passive-aggressive coward that they
would pretend to have left a note that
they didn't really leave would they is
it possible
well as it turns out the answer to all
those questions is yes
the driver typed out that letter printed
it but never actually gave it to the
customer
so i think we could probably declare now
first of all at this point that all
notes or letters left for or by waiters
or delivery drivers or anyone associated
with the food industry they're all fake
all of them there is something about
people in the restaurant business that
compels them as if by some unseen
mystical force to write fake notes i
don't know what it is if you're in the
restaurant industry maybe you can tell
me
what's going on exactly with you people
why do you keep doing this
i can't explain it and this guy doesn't
really explain it himself here's the new
york post they say quote a door dash
delivery man who went viral last week
for leaving a passive-aggressive note
for a habitual non-tipper now says that
the stunt never happened
quote amy is real she's a real habitual
non-tipper but i didn't leave the note
at amy's house
he posted on saturday four days after he
shared a now unavailable video claiming
to have left the note along with the
female customer's order
a subsequent video showed french fry
thug supposedly distributing the money
that he said he received from strangers
on venmo to fellow underpaid door
dashers uh well there you go he included
his venmo in the fake note and the
strangers
you know online for mysterious reasons
were once again eager to send him money
there there are charities and
non-profits out there that work with
actual poor people and sick people and
yet struggle to raise funds meanwhile
any random dummy with a phone can rake
in hundreds or thousands of dollars with
the lamest sob story
children's cancer research probably gets
less funding than whiny waiters and
delivery drivers on tick tock at this
point
it's quite a sad state of affairs
but what about this issue of tipping
door dash drivers
let's look at the the larger and more
serious issue and this is a serious
issue we're told
door dash drivers actually just went on
strike for a whole day a few weeks ago
among their demands were a higher base
pay right now they make between two and
ten dollars per delivery as a base
and they want to know they want to know
that the tip amount from a delivery
before delivering it because when you
order on door dash you're expected to
pay the tip beforehand but apparently
doordash doesn't tell the drivers what
the full amount is until they've
completed the order
and the drivers insist that they should
know the tip ahead of time and then be
able to decide if they want to complete
the order or not based on that now of
course this is all backwards
i can tell you right now i say
unapologetically
i tip very little
or most of the time not at all when i
order from a food delivery service
ubereats doordash sorry guys i'm not
tipping you
and for one thing because i'm not going
to tip you before you've completed the
task that i am tipping you for
the tip is supposed to be in response to
and calibrated based on the quality of
the service provided how can i reward
you for the quality of your service
before you performed it and what happens
when as has happened to me in the past
before i adopted this new policy what
happens when i leave a generous tip and
then the driver takes their married time
bringing the food to me cold and soggy
and absconding with the tip that i
already gave them
but the other issue is that doordash and
ubereats both charge delivery fees along
with other taxes and service fees what
that means is that i'm already paying 65
bucks for a hamburger and a french fries
and now you want me to add an additional
tip on top of it there are limits to my
generosity
or to my capacity for financial
mismanagement
however you want to look at it
well there are two other factors that
work here as well
uh which are which are a little bit
broader and larger
the first is the is the the rather new
idea
that tipping is an act of unconditional
charity where we're expected to pro that
we're expected to perform for people in
the service industry
and as tipping has turned into a form of
financial assistance a sort of endowment
that we're supposed to bequeath on
people
it's also expanded exponentially now
you're expected to walk through life
handing out tips to anyone who wears a
name tag or works a cash register or
hands you food in a plastic bag it's
it's completely out of control
social convention have already
determined
who gets tipped and who doesn't and i
don't see any reason to change any of
that yeah it might have been relatively
arbitrary in some cases we don't tip our
plumbers for example even though a good
case could be made for them
but you have to draw the line somewhere
and it's been drawn
more importantly i'm supposed to tip
based on the quality of the service that
was provided to me not on the level of
my own personal guilt
or on the victimhood resume of the
service worker that i'm dealing with
it's not my job as the customer to make
sure that you're paid a fair wage
i got news for you
you have to work that out with your
employer
so when you hear from people in the
service industry well i'm not paid a
fair wage that's why you got a tip
no that see that's not my i'm not your
employer i don't decide what your wage
is how that how did that become my issue
all of a sudden
see i was at an airport recently and i
heard
two pilots complaining about their
insufficient compensation they were in
the terminal they were just sitting
there talking about it
they were overworked and underpaid
apparently from what they were saying
which which uh which disturbed me
greatly i have to say
and and maybe their compensation is
insufficient i don't know but it would
have been pretty strange and rather
concerning if they if they were in the
plane and they left the cockpit and
walked down the aisle with a tip jar
expecting the passengers to cover the
difference
the passengers are already paying for
the flight they've done their part the
rest is not their concern and shouldn't
be
the second factor is this idea
that every job should provide a living
wage right door dash drivers are upset
that they aren't paid enough they demand
that their customers make up for it even
if the customer is already paying 29 in
additional fees for a 12 bag of fast
food tacos
but how much should a doordash driver
really expect to make anyway you're
simply taking a bag of food
from one location to another
it's something that literally anyone
with a driver's license could do and
even a lot of people without a driver's
license could probably do it and
probably do in fact do it
two to ten dollars plus a few bucks for
tip per delivery seems pretty fair for
that menial task
in fact it seems surprisingly high if
anything
how much do you want if that's not
enough
twenty dollars per delivery forty
dollars should you pull down an
astronaut's salary for picking up
someone's kung pao chicken at panda
express and driving it eight miles to
their apartment
i mean how much is the labor actually
worth that's the question that we are
always losing sight of how much is this
labor actually worth
how much could it possibly be worth
people are already paying a premium just
so they don't have to put on pants and
drive to panda express themselves but
there are limits to our laziness
and you make you make that premium much
higher than it already is and we'll
probably just choose the pants instead
not every job is meant to be a career
not every job is supposed to be
something that you can live off of
i mean door dash driving
some jobs are meant for teenagers who
live at home or people who are looking
to make a bit of extra cash on the side
if you're running door dash orders as
your main source of income
you probably should find another main
source of income
and the good news is that there's 10
million jobs out there so you shouldn't
have any trouble finding it
that would be your wisest course of
action i would say
or
you could make fake notes and solicit
paypal donations as well
that may be your most your most
lucrative path after all though if you
choose that path you will still be in
the end
as this door dash driver is
of course canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical directors austin
stevens
production manager pavel vadasky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
2021
the u.s abandons a thousand americans in
afghanistan lockdowns kill newborn
babies in australia and a new study
finds that only 22 percent of cable news
is news check it out on the michael
knoll show